mike is with us in Arizona hey Mike how
are you kid how you doing Dave better
than I deserve what's up hey so my
question is it's about my daughter she's
13 years old she's got a settlement that
she'll
I'm the conservator of the account right
now and when she turns 18 the money is
hers she lost her mother about nine
years ago at car accident and my
question is really how do I do I tell
her about the money now and kind of
groom her along the way or you know my
concern is that she turns 18 and she
wins the lottery yeah how much is in
there it's about a million whoa what's
it invested in really conservative
mutual funds good okay perfect well done
sir
and um so was she harmed in the accident
she wasn't her mom she passed away and
so based on that they awarded her the
money that's interesting
yeah wrongful death and yeah yeah sure
wife
it was my ex-wife oh okay that's why you
didn't get the money okay that normally
would go to the husband that's what I
was thinking okay now I'm starting to
make sense right okay okay well in our
house we approach it through the lens of
faith because we're a family of faith
we're Christians and so that's one way
you could approach it if you're not a
family of faith then you can approach it
from a nobility kind of standpoint but
the way we talk about it is this is a
responsibility a privilege it is not a
lottery ticket mm-hmm and so having
wealth you know when you say you
sometimes you say so-and-so is a person
of privilege and what that means is they
have the privilege in our house of
handling money for God to handling money
for the good of
others and you get to use some of it for
you but you will get your best life if
you view this as the opportunity to
manage this for the good of your future
children to manage this for the good of
the community and the income you can
create off of it and that kind of thing
or you can be one of those sad stories
that's written up in a magazine where
you live the rest of your life with
regret because you dealt with this like
you were four years old and you ate too
much candy in the candy store and you
throw up and that's what people feel
like when they go through this kind of
inheritance and so we started talking
conceptually about all of that and then
as they approached the age that they
would be managing the money we started
revealing the amounts but we didn't just
spring that on them at adulthood and so
you said she's 13 now yes okay
she's aware there is money there all she
knows is now and there's money for
college she doesn't know any amounts or
anything okay that's what I mean then I
would just start a conversation it
sounds like this the money is there for
college and there's some other money
there it represents enough money that
I'm concerned for you if you don't have
a proper view of it because money will
hurt people when they don't have a
proper view of it when they have a
proper view of it it becomes a tool in
their hands okay and so 13 is a great
time to start having this discussion and
it's not a father to little girl
discussion it's a father to a woman
discussion you're growing her up into
the woman you want her to become okay
and she trusts you already I assume
you're raising her right yeah okay and
so you're the dad she already looks up
to you that's a good thing even though
you're not perfect it's just the nature
of how especially daughters with dads
and just um you know what we want to do
is you start talking about you know
honey when you get some money that
that's a responsibility it's not a it's
not you know
the responsibility is to manage it well
and in our case we say you know we're
managing this for God God owns it
we're managers were stewards and that's
all Christian lingo of course but um you
got to decide you know what the lens is
you talk about this through but the idea
the idea is simply being it's not all
about you if it's all about you you're a
child
adults have other people in mind there
other centered so you you think I should
tell her that was a sin I think you
should tell her today that there's some
money there and that it represents a
risk to her if she doesn't handle it
well it could harm her and we need to
over the next three or four years start
talking about how to handle money and
you need to regularly in the rhythm of
life talk about like you you know she's
13 so you're gonna start talking about
how to have if you haven't already how
to properly analyze the young man that's
at the front door is you'll loose is he
a jerk or is he a prospect right now
we're doing she's got the three
envelopes and she's saving all their
joke yeah well you got a real good
that's a good framework that's a good
framework and just go okay so what I
might job for and I talked to my
teenagers about this when they were 13
and 11 and 12 and and 15 my job is not
to make you look good today my job is to
grow you into a an adult that looks good
I don't want good kids I want kids that
become good adults sometimes they're the
same thing but by you know you know my
job is teach you critical thinking
skills my job is for you to have a
philosophy of life a theology of life
that will serve you into your future and
just keep it on a real high plane like
that and then begin to unfold it in to
what you know and you put more and more
and more weight on this discussion the
closer we get to 18 and I would say
somewhere around 16 we tell her how much
it is okay to where she you know but by
then there's a foundation laid it is not
just surprised right
right and I can't wait two years until
my dad's out of the way and I can go do
whatever I want to do No yeah and you
know what I would do we did too is I
showed them some examples get a
financial calculator just jump online
use one of ours and go you know if you
took a hundred thousand dollars at 18
years old going to show a 13 year old
this if you took a hundred thousand
thousand 18 years old you invested it at
age forty here's how much it'd be at age
sixty here's how much it'd be a hundred
thousand dollars can make you worth tens
of millions of dollars if you didn't
spend it all if you instead invested it
and giving as part of the quake you got
three envelopes give save spent all
money should have some giving some get
saving and some spending and the trick
is to not let this if you surprise her
with it it'll probably won't go well so
I I gradually laid that so by the time
our kids were in their 20s and we opened
up actually how much money we do make
and what our net worth was and they
would be responsible for as managers
when we died they did not feel like they
hit the lottery they felt the weight of
the responsibility which is what you
want to have happen